they don't gotten a little matica
classics
[Music]
number yeah why don't use this mugshot
hey we're trying to play ready to bust
my gun I'm rushing in like let me plug
in with your watch son [ __ ] a rule let's
get you and the 47 so uh so you start or
maybe having back in New York or what
man yeah definitely you know it's good
to be back it was any good spots to eat
out the Arawa know anytime one one tour
be all I'm thinking about is reaching
you riding curry chicken is it about
just strictly about this is exactly what
you said you from you like curry chicken
is something to me that's always been
close to home yeah and like you know in
the hook is like me basically leaving
home and just like you know taking on
the world so was like yo it's like you
know to me telling my mom me telling my
pops like I got job backs I got my own
back to you feel me ain't got to worry
about nothing
as long as I come home for some curry
chicken it's a dinner like as long as I
got that Cody chicken didn't I'm coming
home to
that's that love like that exactly
that's like Oh chicken mean to me so
means yeah home is where the heart is
yeah like you know cover chicken is in
there Daniel
I gotta get back there and make some
curry chicken so let's do it
I'll get a curried chicken waffle B
that's a game-changer right yo you might
kill the game with a game changer right
there be let's do it yeah I think I got
the recipe in my hand maybe we'll go
back in right now something with it we
take this record I'll cop this right say
no more
go back there with this is two in the
wall
yeah remember back in the days and Jesus
right away
this is it man
when we built this place out about two
years ago we was listening to nineteen
ninety nine and I'm in here trying to
all types of fried chicken is for the
grits and we were coming over the menu
and you know two years later we got here
every chick we bout to cook it up chef
Joey on the pot oh yeah it was a good
career I did get up get in there you
don't say like if I get like though like
your static selector right now you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now we turn from a $10
chicken-and-waffle to $15
chicken-and-waffles do something do you
take the gym
so what you think man your mom about
competition Oh
hey I don't know my mom hell that is
fired oh cool
come chicken allowed time wasted man
let's go just loud with this right now
like a man well John yeah we did it
you feel me like it has come to life
it's alive let's say a prayer all right
y'all God is grace God's grace thank you
God for this food and shelter name Jesus
amen amen
let's get it all right you got first man
I hide hey I'm just gonna cook this
waffle down the middle come you ready no
I like my waffles and quarters for the
mercy
you know coconut do have the sitter's
with the rest of the world man you
should do like I like some of the fan
whatever come down have some dinner or
something yeah
serve it up yeah I would it won't sound
like family preser fam you know good I
hope your mom's would be proud of this
dish match our if you would agree you do
something like tomorrow yo do like
another dinner work yeah I'm gonna come
on yeah but you know we're allowed to
make like 12 more days right
it's good man nothing looking good right
there
no I know you ready we got people
outside and everything yeah I'm right
I'm ready to eat moms out there yeah yo
man all right cool
let's do it man
[Music]
[Music]
thank you everybody for coming
[Music]